Before we get started, would
you like some fun dragon facts
for kids?
Yes, I would.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSE MOSTIPAK: So
a dragon has zero
to four legs, coarse
scales, and possibly spikes,
and it may also have wings.
Sometimes they have
horns and hair.
A dragon can usually fly.
Some dragons live in caves.
And dragons hoard precious
metals and jewels.
BARRET SCHLOERKE: Yeah,
I like the last part.
JESSE MOSTIPAK: Gold.
Are you ready to
talk about dragons?
I am.
OK.
In this game, the player or
players, it's the two of us,
we're in a land full of dragons.
The dragons all live in
caves with their large piles
of collected treasure.
Some dragons are friendly
and share their treasure.
Other dragons are hungry and eat
anyone who enters their cave.
The players approach two caves,
one with a friendly dragon
and the other with
the hungry dragon.
But we don't know which
dragon is in which cave,
and we have to choose
between the two.
So we're going to
take all of this
and put it into a Shiny app.
All right.
Let's begin.
If we think about this like
in terms of running an R script,
this wouldn't be the
most complex thing.
Like if I was just going
to do dragonrealm.r,
this is almost,
oh, gosh, this is
what like an if-else statement?
Yeah, with a menu that you
can ask the user for input.
But there's kind of
like three big UIs
that we need to look at.
The intro UI and choose a cave.
There would be like then
the logic that we check
and then ask to play again.
I don't know.
They can appear not up here
if I was to make a game.
The way that I
start a Shiny app.
I haven't programmed a Shiny
app in a really long time.
It's been a month.
So I do Shiny app,
and then I Shift-Tab.
And that, my friends,
is the shortcut
that I have to share with you.
How do we go about
this, Barrett?
I am very inclined to
design a beautiful UI first,
and I know that is like what we
saw with Winston, and Wardle,
with Nick, and Winston.
Should we always be designing
the logic of our app first,
or should we make
it beautiful first?
I am a fan of logic.
So how do we start this?
I really like that flow chart.
So I think we can turn that
into some comments here,
and then we can try to
fill in some functions.
OK.
This is our flow chart.
And so step one is the start.
And I'm going to just be
going back and forth basically
between screens.
So then introductory text.
And then, a player
chooses a cave.
All right, and then we
check for a hungry dragon
or a friendly dragon.
I feel like this is
a false dichotomy.
Like you can be hungry--
I mean, can you be hungry
and friendly, though?
Maybe not.
No, it's usually just hungry.
So you should bring
them a Snickers.
[ROARS]
All right, and then
we ask to play again.
And then we end.
Well, yeah, I mean, I
guess if you play again,
you could go through as
many times as you want.
If you say no, then it's an end.
Well, we'll do a line after
20 and say if yes, go to start.
We can do else.
So where can we do
logic that has nothing
to do with Shiny at all.
So logic that has
nothing to do with Shiny.
I guess what I'm thinking
is introductory text, maybe.
So this is an output.
Can we do a text output?
Yeah, that works for me.
Just going to copy-paste
this introductory text.
Let's actually do one more
thing above line five and add.
I just default h1s, and
let's just say h1 intro.
Like what stage are
we at in this UI.
OK, so h1 intro.
We'll do a comma because
we're working with Shiny.
And I am going to set this
up to run on my viewer pain.
And the text output
doesn't need to be Shiny.
The text output is
expecting an output matchup,
so this is more like a
paragraph, so just p tag.
Look at that.
Boom!
We're done.
OK, let's see.
Is there anything else
we can do that would not
be Shiny related?
I don't think so because
any other text is now
buried behind decisions.
True.
But we can also just
kind of put everything
in one big layout
at the beginning.
And we will only update
certain parts of the UI.
So we could ask them
the question then
for which cave do you want to
do and maybe add in two buttons
OK, so we could do--
actually, let's do this.
Would you like to enter
put that in there.
OK, so which cave
will you go into?
One or two?
And then we want two buttons.
So we could do action
button, input ID,
and we can call it cave 1
Yeah, we can do the label of.
Cave 1, please.
Oh, I miss Shiny.
OK, so this should give us--
oh, and then right next
to each other, too.
I don't know why I expected
them to stack, but perfect.
Fun surprises.
So let's try to separate
the intro in the question.
OK, let's add another
h1 above line 10.
Great.
And probably because we're going
from the intro to the question,
we'll need like a
Continue button.
Oh, I like that.
So you're saying here
we'll do action button.
I put an Id equals continue.
And we'll do maybe like an
intro continue because it seems
to be lots of transitions.
That's a good point.
Intro under.
Oh, yeah.
Under, sorry.
All right, so then I
would say what an answer?
A response?
Consequences.
Yeah, I like that.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYING]
So dramatic.
It's very dramatic.
So this would be a text
output of some kind
because something's happening.
OK but would we do
it as a p for now?
Just as like
You could have win
text and lose text.
Yeah, win text lose text.
OK, and then if we look at our
flow charts, so that's this,
and then we ask if they
want to play again.
Play again, and then that would
be, I guess, another button.
Or two.
Yes, actionButton,
inputId equals play again.
And then we would do
one that is end game.
We can just say no, thank you.
All right.
We'll switch that
inputIds to be underscores
because it's upsetting, and
R doesn't like minus signs
because it's
actually [INAUDIBLE]..
So what I feel like is there
is a couple of directions
we can go.
One is we know when
we play this game,
we're not going to have the
whole thing just laid out.
We're going to see an
intro, and then the button
is going to take us to this
and then right, so there's
different kind of UI
pieces that show or like we
break this UI up into pages
or fancy programming term.
So that's one direction to go.
Another would it be the logic
of like, oh, I click cave 1,
and then I see this
consequence text.
Let's do some of the
logic for hooking up
the buttons because we can
see everything right here.
In that way debugging
is a lot faster
because we don't need to
go through four screens
to see if we want to play again.
And then we can just
print a message just
to know that it hooked up,
but it doesn't actually
have to do anything.
We've got intro_continue as
our action button in our UI.
So now we're going to come
all the way down to server.
And how do I hook up--
oh, my gosh.
My brain is blank.
So we want side effects only.
Side effects, of course.
Do it when the
button is pressed.
So observeEvent.
Sorry, OK.
[SIGHS]
That was like a rough moment.
My brain just forgot everything.
OK, so once the
event expression.
So it's not just
input intro_continue
Yes, spelling of input.
Thank you.
(SINGING) Here programming.
And then we always
add comma curly brackets
because it's always
an expression.
OK, so observeEvent,
input, intro_continue,
and then you said something
really important that I didn't.
We'll do comma curly brackets
because the action that
will take should be
a bigger expression.
So we want to make sure we
have the curly brackets.
And so since we're
just hooking it up,
would we just do like it print?
Is it message?
I like message.
Message, continue button
was pressed or something.
OK.
So if we just run this,
what should happen
is when I click the
Continue button,
we get our message
in our console.
Perfect.
Then we just kind of continue
that for cave 1, cave 2,
play again, and no, thank you.
Correct.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So, when we're talking
about side effects,
could you do a quick recap?
What is a side effect in Shiny?
Side effect is there should
be no follow-up reactivity.
So there's nothing
else to calculate,
and a side effect
would be like printing
a message skimming a file.
Right.
Because if we print
to the console,
there's nothing that's
going to happen after that.
Correct.
Look at that,
all of our buttons.
Whoops, whoops, caught it.
Made a mistake.
Here we go.
Play again, end game.
Excellent.
Buttons are hooked up.
Cool.
And when we go through
this app development,
personally, I'd leave
messages until the very end
because if you may
have hooked it up now
but it may get unhooked
due to something,
and so then it's
just nice to have,
especially since this is
a very flowchart workflow.
Yes.
So you're saying I could
make mistakes in my code
and unhook my buttons.
Yes.
Let's do a little bit more
about the consequences.
[DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS]
Yeah, let's fill in the
dragon logic, the cave logic.
Let's actually make this
function outside of Shiny.
OK.
If I put something down
here, does Shiny ever see it?
Like if I write a function
here, is Shiny going to be like,
oh, there's that function, or
is this like scratch paper?
So it will.
Because it is outside
the server function,
the server function
is only parsed.
It is not executed immediately.
It is only executed when
the file is returned.
The only thing
that you need to do
is 67, where it says
Shiny app, that needs
to be returned from the file.
So that needs to
be the last thing.
That's the only requirement.
So actually, the server
function and the UI definition
above is all free form.
You can do anything
you want in any order
as long as 67 is the last
thing that's returned.
OK, so we're going
to develop a function.
Can we call it
consequences, or are we
going to get ourselves in
trouble with too much naming
things?
Sure.
So we'll set up our function.
And before we do it, we'll
move 67 below our flow chart,
so it's the last thing returned.
Like I didn't hear
anything you just said.
Consequences.
We are going to
write a function.
So the input, the
argument to the function,
well, it's cave 1 or cave 2.
So we could say cave number.
I mean, there's ways that
we can actually dial it down
to a coin flip.
But I like the idea
of cave number.
Is this where we would set
like friendly dragon, not
friendly dragon?
How would you define
friendly dragon in code.
That's the thing,
so if we're doing
a coin toss, eventually friendly
dragon the match or the not
match.
I guess I would say like,
well, it theoretically
doesn't matter.
We just have to make a decision.
I would want the friendly
dragon to be a match.
He's going to be--
I like it.
That idea goes really well
because if we had three caves,
you could have two angry
dragons and one friendly dragon.
I'm more thinking this of like
a coin toss at a basketball game
or football game.
If you guessed the toss, or
you guessed the random value,
then you win.
And so you could
have a six-sided die.
And if you guess
the side of the die,
you found the friendly
dragon or two-sided die.
Right.
So would we just
sample one or two?
Yes.
OK.
I'm going to sample.
So sample is going to be--
is it just one to two?
Size equals one.
Replace equals fall.
I guess replace doesn't
actually matter.
Correct, because size
is one, and that's always.
Let's go ahead and kill
the app so that you can run
line 69 like five-six times.
Oh, there we go.
OK.
Buy a lottery ticket.
You got a lot of it.
That is unexpected.
All right, so we're
going to sample,
and then we want to
assign this to something.
Yeah.
We could say friendly.
OK, so basically, I
want if cave number.
Well, wait a minute.
I want my cave number,
so that's whatever
button they've pressed.
So we can imagine
that number one or two.
So what?
I just do cave number
equals friendly?
Then, if that's true,
what would you do?
So I guess it would be
something like congratulations,
you have a new dragon friend.
And what if it's not friendly?
So then it would be else
womp womp, you've been eaten.
OK, that's the basic logic.
So if the cave number
equals whatever we've set
is-- so if we have
a match, great,
you've got a dragon friend.
If not, you've been eaten.
So this is fairly
straightforward,
but now we need to hook up
consequences to button press.
Before we do that, we
test the function just
to see that it
works as we expect.
All right, so the
best way to test this
Oh, same idea
but starting at 67.
Thank you.
All right, so then I could
do like friendly one, no,
because that's not
the name function.
Oh, we got eaten.
All right, we've got
a new dragon friend.
So it's picking up.
Yeah, it looks perfect.
It works.
We wrote a function.
OK, so now we
have consequences.
This returns the response text.
So that is pretty cool.
Can we scroll up to
the UI definition
to see the response
text is a text output?
I think you're wanting that
[INAUDIBLE],, yeah, text output.
We could call this
consequence text, maybe?
OK.
So outputId equals consequence.
So then we can observe
event in cave one or two
like we are doing.
But a little bit farther,
we about ready to do.
I'm not putting a reactive
inside my observer, right?
Correct.
I feel like that's just
an unfriendly dragon.
That's like an unfriendly
dragon that will climb out
of your computer.
We do not put reactor
inside observers
Or renders.
Or renders, but
renders are-- yeah, yeah.
Renders are reactive-ish.
Yeah, so we don't do that.
So we still need to
render text somewhere.
So, where do we do that?
Well, obviously, it's
outside the observer.
So we can just start it then?
Since it's near cave 1
cave 2 logic and not here
to play again, let's
just do it after 55.
OK, so in here.
And this would be output,
and then this has to match.
The really long
name descriptive.
It's descriptive.
All right, so I'll
put consequence_text.
And could we just do
consequences function?
So, if we did
that, there would be
no reactive or reactivity act.
You would not be able to click
a button because consequences
would only occur once.
So we need a render text to
pair with the text output.
OK, so then can it be
rendered text consequences?
Closer, warmer.
So consequences is now inside
the render text, great.
But we haven't given
it like a cave number.
Yes.
So I want the output
of consequences_text,
and then I wanted to print
either friendly or not friendly
response based on cave number.
And cave number is going to be
whether this button was pressed
or this button was pressed.
So if we were to write
this in normal R code,
how would you,
not reactive code,
would you use a
variable in between?
Yes.
Yeah, I would say
like cave number--
can I put that in?
Where would I put
my cave number?
Let's go ahead and put a
cave number in there in 57.
Yeah, cave number.
Then we'll pretend that
it's reactive and will then
create it.
So we have our
cave number there.
Right.
OK, so then is it cave
number is it reactiveVal?
I like reactiveVal.
There might be a
more elegant solution
by doing reactive
or something else,
but I like the idea
of doing reactiveVal.
It's very explicit, and you
have very fine-tuned control.
OK, so then my
reactiveVal is--
I guess why I'm still
stuck is like I have
two separate
buttons, and I don't
know how to put which one was
clicked inside my reactive.
So if we were to do this
in a normal if statement,
you'd be like, if button
was pressed, then code.
And you would say like one is
cave [INAUDIBLE] and then else
if button two is pressed,
then two is cave [INAUDIBLE]..
So how do we assign
to a reactive value?
How do we update
the reactiveVal?
Is there an update?
Is there like an
update function?
Not yet.
So let's go ahead and
go after your line 50.
As cave 1 was
pressed in line 50,
we know we're in that situation.
So then we'll say
cave_number parentheses 1.
Wait, cave.
Don't forget
number, and C is one.
Wait, what the heck is that?
So that's how you can
update a reactiveVal.
You submit new no.
What!
So then this would
be cave number two?
Yes.
And is this just
going to work now?
I hope so--
text output.
Missing a T.
Argument is of length zero.
Correct.
So this is actually a
consequence function.
But we can probably skip
the consequences function
because I like how it is.
It's very independent of Shiny.
We'll leave it as is.
But let's update our
render text on line 60.
And this is also
why earlier we were
trying to move in
very small steps
because we have a
thing of length zero,
and we did like five
different things in the app,
So which one was it?
So inside the render text,
actually what we can do in 59--
let's do this one first.
59, the default value is null.
Well, let's just pretend that
they always picked cave 1.
So let's say the
reactiveVal one.
OK, so we would just do that?
Yeah.
And then let's run the app and
see if that fixes our zero.
Great.
So stuff is happening
in the console
but is not happening there.
So let's go check our function.
OK, Yes.
So we've got a message.
Great, so our function
prints out a message.
So if we were running
this independent of Shiny,
our messages printing
out to the console.
We were doing this like in
a standard R script that
is behaving as we would expect.
True, but the function
needs to return the text,
not display the text.
So can I just do return?
You can do return.
Since it's also the last
thing and the function,
you can just take off
the return parentheses.
Oh.
And it'll take--
yeah, perfect.
Easier.
So if we reload, OK.
Great.
And this is now kind of fun
because the consequences
is random.
It's not like OK, everyone
is always friendly.
You refresh the app
three or four times.
Then the consequence
is text should change.
You're very lucky.
There we go.
OK, so we got the
consequences text to come on.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
We've changed it works.
Cool.
Great, but we're still
not hooked up to button.
That's OK.
So that's OK.
Oh, so you should be able
to hit cave 1 cave 2,
and it should at least
may be the same text.
Yeah, so it's not
like actually reading--
Oh, because no, because it's
recalculating each time.
We haven't linked it up.
Recalculates each time.
OK.
So each time I
click this button,
it is independently
running sample,
but you should only
be able to guess once.
And so that's where like
intro should only be displayed.
Then questions should
only be displayed.
You click the button once,
then you go immediately
to the consequences.
You're not allowed to
click the button again.
Got it.
OK, so is this where we-- so
we've got the logic plugged
in, is this where we start--
so is this now where we
would chop everything up
into four screens?
Sounds good to me.
OK, you sent me a Slack
message, and my response was,
"The what?"
The what?
So you had said today is
going to be all about test panel
type equals in tab panel
body with transitions
via observe event and
update tabsetPanel.
If you actually want to pull
up the help for tabsetPanel
in that quadrant there.
Perfect.
Great.
And so, let's scroll down
and look at the examples.
That's how we read
the help documentation.
And what we're going to
do is this second example,
the UI one in the middle
where we have a tabPanelBody.
Oh, down here.
So, tabsetPanel is
something that you
can click on to change
the different tab sets.
If you do type is hidden, those
things that you can click on
disappear like the
titles are gone.
And, yes, a little spooky,
but the way you transition
is using the update
tabsetPanel function.
So it's programmatic.
So we know when the
button is clicked,
we automatically change
to the next thing.
We know when something happens,
we change the next one.
It's not spooky.
But we can do this
as a tab panel
and then transition to a
tabPanelBody once it works.
OK, so I'm not doing a
sidebar layout main panel,
but I would pick up
from like tab panel?
Yes.
So we can just
tabsetPanel there.
Oh, tabsetPanel.
Sorry.
Thank you.
OK, and then all of
this goes inside of it?
Everything?
Well, all of my UI?
All the UI except for 40.
Yeah, there we go.
All right, so I'll just do
a little bit of that and that.
All right, so we are now
inside of a tabsetPanel.
And let's now add in the
ID for the tabsetPanel.
OK.
So ID is going to
be a dragon tabs?
Yeah, dragon tab.
Great.
Then let's not do
type is hidden.
Maybe we write it out
and then comment it.
Great.
And then let's do--
all right, well, our first
one is going to be a--
Yeah.
So am I going to put each
chunk inside tabPanelBody?
Let's do it as
a tabPanel first,
but, yes, the contents will
be the second argument.
Got it.
So it'd be tabPanel, and
then this will be intro.
Yes.
I like short, simple names
here, even though they may not
look pretty.
Feeling a little
attacked, but that's fine.
No, no.
I like what you did
because if there's spaces,
we can't update it.
Programmatically, that's easily.
OK, I was going to show
off my one cool trick.
All right, intro,
question, and then
the way that I'm
doing this, I'm just
leaving my headings in here.
I'm not going to worry
about it too much.
I'm going to remember to
move my commas around.
This is the tabPanel.
And this will be consequences.
There are consequences when
you choose consequences
as your text because
then you have to type it.
If you want, you could
actually put the play again
in the consequences.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Kind of.
You died.
Do you want to play again?
Yeah, that's fair.
I feel like that's
usually where it shows up.
Space, then I grab these guys.
Oh, gosh.
All right, made a mess.
Here we go.
Fixed it.
Is that everyone?
I think so.
I'm not getting any errors.
OK, so I put
everything in tabPanel.
If I run it.
Good.
So let's switch to the question,
switch to the consequences.
One, we would absolutely
use this like in a report.
We wouldn't necessarily
like continue,
but data science, data
analyst, business intelligence,
like this is, oh, here are
some intro text or instructions
and here's that.
So this does relate
to data science.
I promise.
All right, so we've made panels.
Now, what do we do?
So, the update method,
updateTabsetPanel, can be done.
So it's programmatic
updating, and that
can be done with a regular
tabPanel or tapPanelBody.
It's required for tapPanelBody.
So let's go ahead and try to do
this updateTabsetPanel for all
of our output or observance.
OK, so one thing that
I'm noticing in the help
documentation is
updateTabsetPanel is actually
happening in our
server function.
So it's not something
we're applying into our UI.
We're putting it into
our server function.
Correct.
So what I'm seeing is
in our server function,
we have observed events.
We have lots of observers.
We've got a button pressed.
Would I put update tab set
panel around all of my messages?
Just after.
I mean, you can have many lines
of code in the observer event,
like curly bracket section.
That's why we do
a curly bracket.
So we can just paste
it there like that?
Mm-hmm.
But we need to fill out the
details of where we're going to
and how we're getting there.
So first argument is it needs
to be the session object.
So we'll just do session
comma because you're
providing that on 55.
OK, so now my second
argument says hidden tabs.
That will match to the
ID of the big tabsetPanel.
And we said that
was dragon tabs.
So we are professionals.
And then selected,
what is this refer?
Well, what's the next argument?
I guess is what I'm saying.
Your destination.
Where would you like to go?
I would like to go
to my cave section.
So instead of intro, I
would like to go to--
can I just put a question?
Yes, question.
Oh, that's it-- so
selected equals question.
Yes.
All right.
Good.
Let's see if the app works.
Yeah, we got to test this.
Baby steps.
You are in a land
full of dragons.
Oh, that's so cool!
OK, so then?
So 59 can now be copy-pasted
in a lot of different places.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Boom.
Yay!
And then your
console is freed up
like everything
is nice and neat.
Look at that.
So now you said what you
had some other things,
other tricks.
There's the hidden.
So let's turn
this into hidden.
Yes, a type hidden.
Is that it?
We need to change
tabPanelBody.
So now it's tabPanel
to tabPanelBody.
Well, Boday.
I can't remember
if I did a capital B.
You know what we
can do, we're going
to come to friend the
help documentation.
Tab
And no body, yep.
And the signature for the
function technically changed.
So for a tapPanel,
the ID defaults
to the title, which the
title is the first argument.
And I just had to
provide simple names that
could be interpreted as an ID.
But a tapPanelBody, the
first argument is the ID.
So it switches a
little bit, but just
because we use simple names
and we didn't do anything else,
it'll work out.
It'll still work.
We don't have to change it.
Because if I had done like
consequences of decisions,
that's very hard to--
That would be really bad
for where we are right now.
OK.
Let's do that.
So now, oh, I'm so excited.
I think I know what's
going to happen.
So it took away our tabs.
There's nothing.
So now we can completely
direct someone.
Oh, my gosh.
It works!
I feel like there's a lot
of good things that we did
and we learned here.
I think this, to me, is such
an interesting-- obviously,
making games is a ton of fun.
I learned so much
just doing this.
But then I'm thinking like
use cases for this like.
If you want to like direct
someone through your app,
this would be really useful,
or you can direct them
and give them choices.
That's really powerful.
Yeah, force the workflow
of your application.
When you go to intro, you
can only go to the question.
You cannot go to consequences.
You have to go to question.
Question, you can only
go to the consequences.
Barret, this was so cool.
It was so--
I don't want to say it was easy
because I still get stumped
on reactivity,
but like I thought
this would be, the
hard part was hiding
the tabs and the conditional
stuff, but that was ridiculous.
That was so easy.
You can also imagine if you
didn't have the transition
logic and the other things.
If we hid everything first,
it's really hard to debug.
How do if your consequences
are working right now?
I don't know.
Just do the
tapPanels at the end.
Lesson learned.
Thank you for not
letting me go down
the path I tried to go down.